Hey, this is Presh Talwalkar and you're watching Mind Your Decisions.
A square with a side length of five is
positioned with its corner in the center of a square with a side length of four as shown in the diagram.
One side of the overlapping region between the two squares is equal to three.
The puzzle is to calculate the area of the overlap between the two squares.
That is, to calculate the area of the red shape.
I thank Ohad from Israel for suggesting this problem. Can you figure it out?
Give this problem a try and when you're ready keep watching the video for a solution.
So, how can we figure this problem out?
Well, the first thing is the side of three is actually irrelevant to this problem. We'll remove it.
Next we'll draw blue lines to extend the sides of the square as shown.
What does this do?
Notice the square with a side length of four is now divided into four identical shapes,
each with an area equal to the red shape.
Therefore,
each shape is equal to one-fourth of the squares area.
So the red region has an area equal to the area of the square,
which is 4 times 4, or 4 squared,
and then we divide it by 4
This will be equal to 4.
Amazing!
In fact, we can extend this problem that the area of overlap between the two
squares always has an area of 4
So we consider a square with a side length of 4 and then we have a square with a side length of 5.
What we'll do is we'll create a tiling where we have four different squares with a side length of five.
Notice the square with a side of four is
divided into four identical shapes right
now, each with an area equal to four.
Now this will be true even as we rotate the squares with a side length of five.
We still have the square with the side length of four being divided into four identical shapes each with an area equal to four.
Now we can continue the symmetry as we rotate the larger squares.
The square with a side length of four is always divided into four different identical shapes.
Therefore each will have an area that's one-fourth the area of the square.
It's a pretty neat problem,
and rotational symmetry solves this like magic.
Did you figure it out?
Thanks for watching this video. These math videos, which can be watched for free,
inspire and build confidence for people around the world and they already have over a hundred million views. Let's share the beauty of mathematics
With your help we can "math" the world a better place.
Please subscribe for free to get the newest videos, watch and share all of Mind Your Decisions videos,
email me a puzzle presh [at] mindyourdecisions [dot] com,
read my books, which are linked in the video description, and if you so choose you can support me on Patreon to earn exclusive rewards.
Thanks for watching and thanks for your support.